The job of the moderator, in addition to those already mentioned, concerning
preparation and follow-up, include the following. The moderator should determine
whether the participants have done the necessary preparatory work. If necessary,
the moderator should abort the review if the team is not prepared. Why,
after all, go through an expensive meeting if it's not going to be effective?
The moderator should also evaluate whether the work to be reviewed is actually
ready for review. Let's say it's a code review. And the organization has
guidelines that say, before code review the code must be completed,
it must be successfully compiled and it must go through unit tests,
the moderator can then check whether those events have happened and
if not, send it back and reschedule the meeting. A moderator is responsible for
running the meeting. Keeping the participants on track, arbitrating any
differences, and managing time. Moderation is a skilled activity and
moderators typically have under, undergone some kind of training at the task.
Finally, moderators should be technically competent, but
not necessarily expert on the specific artifact of technology being reviewed.